Ehi ciao Sto per salire sul palco aiuto
Ehi Lara forza prendi un bel respiro e
guarda in faccia la tua paura parla con
lei e controlla la e non ti vergognare
mai delle tue insicurezze ah ah aspetta
sono arrivati a prendermi c'è qualcuno
che vuole salutarti Ciao Lara se riesci
a fare ciò che sai fare meglio e sei
felice di farlo allora sei più avanti
nella vita della maggior parte delle
persone Ehi ti passo Lara ha bisogno di
te che succede
Ricorda di essere sempre grata per tutto
quello che sei e divertiti c'è qualcuno
che vuole parlarti Ciao bellezza ci
siamo quasi vivi ogni momento al massimo
e goditi tutto quello che riceverai sono
con te Salve dolcezza Sono appena
rientrato da un viaggetto niente male
alla scoperta di un'antica tribù
cannibale in Amazzonia Prova solo a
immaginare Comunque ti lascio sola pochi
mesi e guarda che cosa mi combini Dunque
so che Parlerai di emozioni portatrici
di significati e di formidabili energie
per la nostra esistenza Io credo che
questo possa servire a tutti per
ricordare chi siamo e come essere felici
rimani sempre un instancabile sognatrice
ad occhi aperti a presto
il modo più vero per sentire e ascoltare
dice il teologo francese
Yves congar
Che cosa hai provato quando hai
ascoltato questa telefonata
c'è chi riconosce la voce del suo attore
preferito C'è chi si concentra sul
contenuto c'è chi non si concentra né la
voce né su contenuto e il messaggio
passa inosservato e non c'è nulla di
male non esistono risposte giuste o
risposte sbagliate Esiste la risposta
la tua personale risposta
ora dai un nome
all'emozione che hai provato Gioia
stupore tristezza disinteresse sono
tutte emozioni che fanno parte di te e
che sei in grado di riconoscere
Ecco questa è la prima lezione da tener
presente quando parliamo di intelligenza
emotiva cioè tutti noi siamo fatti di
emozioni che ci rendono unici
Come dice il padre dell'intelligenza
emotiva Goleman siamo fatti del 20% di
intelligenza
cognitiva quindi solo il 20%, e dell'80%
di intelligenza emotiva
Questo vuol dire che sono le emozioni
che ci fanno scegliere cosa fare quando
farlo e perché farlo
le emozioni sono soggettive
e se noi siamo in grado di riconoscerle
siamo già su una buona strada per
realizzare i nostri sogni ad occhi
aperti
l'educazione emotiva poi passa
attraverso una serie di step attraverso
anche il riconoscimento delle nostre
emozioni e anche la trasformazione anche
la capacità di saper gestire senza
sopprimerle
domandiamoci
che me ne faccio di questa emozione come
come posso sfruttarla a mio vantaggio e
indovina un po'
appena impari a riconoscere e gestire le
tue emozioni
riconosci e gestisci quelle degli altri
attraverso l'empatia che ti serve a
creare delle relazioni sociali positive
Ed è proprio sull'empatia che si fondano
tutte le storie storie Sì storie come la
storia di quella bambina che nasce in un
piccolo paese da una sana famiglia che
la lascia sempre libera di fare tutto
quello che vuole è una bambina
scalmanata e curiosa il padre la porta
per la prima volta a 8 anni al cinema a
vedere la versione animata del film Lo
schiaccianoci il film racconta la storia
di Clara figlia di un ricco magnate
russo che riceve in dono a Natale Uno
schiaccianoci dalle fattezze di
soldatino
entusiasta la bambina si addormenta con
il suo schiaccianoci
immaginando un mondo che da lì a poco
prenderà vita sotto i suoi occhi tra
mille avventure Lo schiaccianoci alla
fine si trasforma in uno splendido
Principe
Ma alla fine è tutto un sogno un sogno
ad occhi chiusi la bambina si sveglia
sempre sotto l'albero di Natale con in
grembo il suo dono inanimato
inanimato
e rimanerle sono solo ricordi di
maybolanti
avventure
e storie da raccontare Ecco quel giorno
la bambina
esce da quel cinema molto delusa ma con
la voglia di crescere e di realizzare i
suoi sogni ad occhi aperti Sarà capitato
anche a te magari di
rimanere deluso per qualcosa che non è
andato per il verso giusto come ti sei
comportato cosa hai fatto
il modo migliore per sentire e ascoltare
Anzi e ascoltarti
la bambina cresce e nonostante la
delusione torna al cinema e capisce che
grazie complice Il buio della sala
Continua a sognare continua a esprimere
le proprie emozioni di cui magari si
vergogna piangere
si tormenta come come fai tu quando vai
al cinema e ti emozioni ad ascoltare le
voci di quei personaggi che che ascolti
nel tuo film preferito magari
ecco
tutto questo succede all'interno di una
sala di una sala buia di una sala che ti
rende partecipe di conoscere te stesso
Ed eccola qui
questa bambina un po' cresciuta
ho creato per la prima volta
Io sono ovviamente la reciterei ho
creato per la prima volta il primo
Format di Story voicing mi sdoppio che
mette in scena i migliori doppiatori del
cinema italiano e le loro
interpretazioni attraverso la scrittura
di sceneggiature originali tra ricordi
cinema e appunto storie interpretate da
loro
che mettono in scena
il mio mondo il mio modo di vedere anche
la vita il cinema Secondo me non solo ti
aiuta
a gestire le tue emozioni o comunque a
esporle Ma ti insegna anche dei concetti
chiave dei concetti che ricordi in
maniera molto più facile rispetto a
quando ascolti una normale lezione
ad esempio se ti chiedessi di
se ti chiedessi di recitarmi un versetto
della Bibbia magari non saresti in grado
di farlo ma se ti dico
Ezechiele 25 17
a qualcuno potrà venire in mente il film
di Pulp Fiction E magari sa anche
recitarmi le prime frasi del versetto Se
ti dico Vendimi questa penna
per qualcuno potrà sembrare una normale
esortazione Ma per chi ha visto il film
The Wolf of the Wall Street Allora sa di
cosa sto parlando e anche la lezione di
vendita che viene messa in scena
Se ti dico capitano o mio capitano
molti sapranno ricondurre le prime frasi
della poesia più volte citata nel film
L'attimo fuggente risultato insegnare
comunicazione filosofia marketing
attraverso il cinema e divertente utile
e crea lezioni che ti rimangono che ti
rimangono impresse nella memoria
ma non è solo questo il cinema il cinema
è molto di più
il modo più vero per sentire e ascoltare
Anzi io direi e ascoltarci
insieme
le emozioni se condivise sono molto più
potenti Nell'era adesso dello streaming
del Social siamo tutti più abituati Sì A
emozionarci ma da soli chiusi in camera
in pausa pranzo scrollare il cellulare
dimenticando
dimenticando il grandissimo valore della
condivisione che alla base dell'empatia
ci stiamo dimenticando di quella
straordinaria e tradizionale
bellezza della sala buia
della sala scura teatro di mille storie
e avventure del fastidioso rumore dei
pop corn del tuo vicino di posto
del
dell'ammonizioni a quello che sta dietro
di te perché ha lasciato il cellulare
acceso
dell'infinito tenerezza di tenere
stretta la mano alla persona che ti sta
vicino al tuo fianco durante tutta la
durata del film fino a quando non si
accendono le luci fino a quando in un
attimo ritorni alla realtà e subito con
uno sguardo capisci cosa pensa l'altra
persona della storia che avete appena
visto insieme
La vita è fatta di piccoli piccoli
attimi da collezionare
da collezionare insieme
condividiamo le nostre
emozioni condividiamo i nostri attimi
siamo capaci di capirci cerchiamo di
capirci attraverso noi stessi e
attraverso gli altri e soprattutto
cerchiamo di riconoscere le emozioni
come opportunità di crescita personale
che ti fanno affrontare la vita di tutti
i giorni
non esiste una bacchetta magica esistono
per non esiste effettivamente una
bacchetta magica per realizzare i tuoi
sogni esistono solo
scelte Non sbagliate e non giuste le tue
scelte quindi
apri gli occhi
guardati dentro e sogna ad occhi aperti
[Applauso]